You don't want him dressed up because,
uh,
you know,
I,
when I do this course and when I do the first half of their French course,
I do a lecture on the bourgeoisie,
the middle classes and middleclass there's a form of a self identity that was
constructed in a way being a worker was constructed or being a noble.
And one day I was about to come off and go out,
you know,
I'll go out among you all and talk about Dmea and show you some dummy,
a slides about the bourgeoisie.
And my wife said to me,
you can't go talk about the bush.
Was he looking like you usually do.
You got to look like you mean it,
like you have a vague sense of knowing it.
And so as a result,
look at this.
So I wear this about once a year.
You know,
unfortunately,
you know,
I wear to funerals and last time I wore was uh,
uh,
something.
Bill Clinton had a through mutual friends.
Uh,
and I only have one tie that I share with my son and,
and uh,
we had to find them another son.
Uh,
another a tie underneath the soccer shoes.
And um,
then we got into New York and went to this party and we're all dolled up,
you know,
and all that.
And then we went out to a restaurant,
I lost my tie,
my one tie and the last time I bought a tie like ties cost $15.
And then so I in Ann Arbor I bought a tie for,
this is $75 tie.
So this is my only tight.
So that's a long way of answering your question,
but why I look like this today,
but I hope to make some sense of that,
you know,
in,
in the lecture.
So thank you very much.
I didn't set that question up.
Did I didn't ask you please,
please ask that question.
But,
but,
but I want you,
you know,
when you're looking at me dress,
it's not Halloween.
That's the first thing I thought.
When you're looking at me dressed like this,
please try to think knowing me a little bit as you do.
Why was that?
It meant a lot to dress like this in the 19th century because the middleclass
has started dressing like this and the 19th century dark with a little bit of
color.
And when you see dome,
Yay are you see Della quads famous,
which I forgot the slide,
Liberty League and the people.
And you see that we're the bourgeois.
There was top hat,
he's dressed in a bourgeois uni like this.
And so,
uh,
that emerges out of the bourgeois century.
And so while last time we talked about class,
the construction of class identity for ordinary people,
for working people,
uh,
the abortion with he had,
has had a strongest sense of self as a,
of self identity as any social class you could imagine.
And it was his all,
I'll make the point in a minute.
It was,
it was a difficult to get into that class if you weren't born into it,
but it,
and,
and it was,
uh,
the fear of falling out of it with something that,
that helps,
uh,
helps motivate lots of political things in the 19th century.
Uh,
and the 19th century in terms of,
of being the bourgeois century.
One of the things you see in,
in,
um,
in countries,
particularly in western Europe and Great Britain,
in,
in France,
uh,
and in Germany and in Italy,
as you see in the middle classes,
wanting the political power that commensurate with their economic status.
I,
and if in the 18th century,
I mean,
this is one of those truisms that happens to be true and can be exaggerated.
But if you know the aristocracy,
you're born into the aristocracy.
If you get,
if you hit the big time and you get lucky,
you can buy your way in thanks to the baroque French monarchy.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the ideal Aristocrat,
and this was what [inaudible] would have talked about,
about him or herself,
uh,
was born into,
the aristocracy through blood,
uh,
through family.
Uh,
it wasn't a cheap,
I mean,
ascribed status.
And in the 19th century,
one of the things that happens with the French revolution and with Napoleon I is
that the middle class person seemed and middleclass values,
uh,
seem to be something to be emulated.
And once we've got an increase in,
in the wealth of the middle classes and the diversity and complexity that I'll
talk about in a minute,
then you wanted to political power,
he one the right to vote,
you wanted access to,
to information through the press and the print culture.
All of these things are closely tied to the middle classes.
So that's what I'm going to talk about today.
Uh,
most of it is about the bourgeois culture.
and so that's why I'm,
I'm dressed dressed like this,
and I assure you that the minute this lecture is over,
I will go back and like,
like I could never compare myself to Clark Kent,
but I will find my phone booth and change back into normal,
normal duds.
So let's talk a little bit about the,
uh,
about the middle class,
in,
in the bourgeois,
uh,
in the bourgeois a century now.
Uh,
the middle classes or the Boers was z,
uh,
in our terms that we conveniently use a marks,
you know,
talked about the wars,
was he as being as extremely homogenous class.
Uh,
in fact,
the word bourgeois has really more cultural connotations maybe then,
uh,
then,
um,
objectives or social categorization,
a living bourgeois in a bourgeois manner.
And we'll see some aspects of that in terms of private access to private space,
uh,
middleclass concept of childhood,
and that sort of thing.
So middle classes is probably a better term.
A bourgeois is equivalent of burger a middle classes is probably for our point
of view,
uh,
a better term.
It seems other odd to be talking about that,
you know,
the English,
uh,
Bush was z of leads of what,
about which there's,
but there's an excellent book.
Ah,
eh,
because bourgeois after all is a,
it started out as a,
as a French word,
but in,
in,
in using an Indian insisting on the term middle classes,
what I'm suggesting,
I is the enormous complexity of the middle class.
There wasn't just one middleclass yet.
Yet the middleclass is shared some,
you know,
cultural values and symbols,
uh,
in common.
And,
uh,
when challenged by ordinary people could snap back,
in an extremely cohesive,
cohesive,
uh,
class based manner and marks,
had some of that,
um,
quite,
uh,
correctly.
Now I'm
in a Parisian newspaper called,
there's,
you're not that day they bought in 1847,
someone actually did a pretty damn good job of describing the bourgeoisie.
The bourgeoisie is not a class.
The person argued it isn't a position.
One inquires that position and when loses it work thrift and ability confer it,
he argued,
referring to himself.
Of course,
vice dissipation and idleness mean that it can be lost.
Um,
and so that old kind of,
uh,
aristocratic,
ethos of not working,
of being idle,
uh,
although it can be exaggerated as we've seen in the 17th and 18th century,
nonetheless,
there was something,
uh,
to it,
it,
you know,
an 18th century noble let his fingernails grow long,
uh,
as sort of just hung out showing,
his,
uh,
his a good taste to by living in,
in an idle aristocratic,
uh,
manner.
Uh,
the bourgeoise he did anything but that work was part of how they believed to
get ahead.
And I'm getting ahead is what they wanted to do.
Now,
the French revolution,
and here's an important point,
I guess,
um,
open the way by removing legal blocks in very many places to the career,
open to talents.
And Napoleon used to say,
say tediously,
uh,
that,
in each,
uh,
soldiers backpack,
there was a Marshall's by tall or staff that you could get promoted with,
with good work,
hard work if you didn't get your head blown off,
uh,
in one of these battles.
Uh,
but certainly one of the things that comes out of his,
his insistence on service to the state,
uh,
is creating a whole series of rewards that,
that,
uh,
recompensed a virtuous action and hard work.
I mean,
that's what the lady who owned a donor,
the legion of honor was all about and making money with part of it.
And of course it's,
it's always,
uh,
in the 19th century.
Would,
what sort of classic to poke fun at it?
Bourgeois culture in some cases,
the lack of it.
Uh,
and,
and to,
uh,
ascribe to the middle classes,
sort of Philistine habits in which making money was really the only thing that
that counted.
Now,
certainly Friedrich Engels Marx as partner,
uh,
obsessed with the as well,
he should have been with the slums of,
of,
uh,
the satanic mills of Manchester.
He wants,
uh,
wrote the following.
He says,
one day I wrote,
I walked with one of these middleclass gentlemen in demand Chester.
I spoke to him about the disgraceful,
unhealthy slums and drew his attention to the disgusting condition of that part
of town in which the factory workers lived.
I declared that I'd never seen so badly built a town in my life.
He listened,
listened patiently,
uh,
and at the end of the corner of a street at which we parted,
he remarked,
and yet there is a good deal of money to be made here.
Good morning sir.
And he walked away.
One employer wrote in the 1830s that that uh,
relative to the work to his workers is that the worker,
quote unquote,
I couldn't invent this should be constantly harassed by need a four,
then he will not set his children a bad example.
And his poverty will be the guarantee of good behavior.
Now of course,
this is,
you know,
this is the character of,
of middleclass self absorbed and of,
of narcissism,
of,
of kind of this and veteran cruelty to,
uh,
to the classes below them.
On the other hand,
I mean,
the more we study the middle classes and then the 1960s people were leaving to
study in the middle classes because I didn't like them very much.
Uh,
you know,
they studied workers,
but,
but there's been an awful lot of good work done on the middle classes.
Among my dear friend Peter Gay has five volumes,
uh,
of the bourgeois century.
Uh,
take on the idea that the middleclass lived without passion.
uh,
and,
we're,
we're Philistines and that sort of thing.
And the more we look at the middle class now,
we,
we see certainly that,
that no matter where you look,
that there are a,
one of the things the middleclass people did was form voluntary associations,
voluntary associations.
Aristocrats didn't form voluntary associations.
They didn't need to.
The middleclass form voluntary associations,
and many of these refer extremely charitable purposes,
uh,
particularly in,
um,
in,
in Britain.
I mean,
again,
the study that I referred to by somebody called Morris,
uh,
I think it's Morris on leads,
chose to kind of richness and depth to these voluntary associations in which
people try to do,
uh,
to do an awful lot for ordinary people.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
it,
it has a sense of moralizing.
There's always this sort of top down look about moralizing them,
trying to get the,
the workers to,
to drink less,
trying to get them to go to church,
uh,
trying to get their them to,
when it was possible for their children's is to become educated in the stay in
school.
And there's always this tension between families who needed children's income,
however small that was,
and across the 19th century,
uh,
over very long period,
laws.
Uh,
finally,
by the end of the century in,
in,
in most places,
making,
uh,
at least primary education,
obligatory and in most cases,
uh,
free.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
here's a ridiculous example.
It's not a ridiculous example.
If you love animals,
I mean,
I'm a cat person and as I already said,
but this is Heidi for the protection of cruelty to animals.
I mean,
these sorts of organizations,
uh,
really,
you know,
we're one of the classic examples of bourgeois voluntary associations.
I mean,
doing good things.
They also get together to hang out with each other and sort of,
uh,
try to gauge who has more money than the other and they get together for social
reasons and the coffee houses of England and,
and,
uh,
in the voluntary,
the clubs,
the circles you call them in France,
and then their equivalents in Germany and Italy and in Spain.
But,
but,
uh,
one of the more,
more,
uh,
ludicrous,
kind of,
uh,
Devi,
well,
we call it Divya,
uh,
a model of one of the,
society for the protection of cruelty to animals was,
and one of the organizations in France has said,
one must love animals,
but not fraternize with animals.
I don't know what that means,
but the main thing is that they want it to save a animals from,
uh,
from being beaten,
almost beaten to death and in many cases of horses.
And,
and you can see how in,
in places in which bull fighting over the long run in the 19th and 20th century,
such as the south,
very south of France and in Spain,
there were always movements to try to,
you know,
protect the bowls were,
seems like a very,
uh,
reasonable,
thing to do.
So,
uh,
for all of those are bad press that the middleclass has had and you can read
some of this bad press and what you're reading or there was also this good side
that that should be a evoked as well.
Um,
um,
that's a period.
And then certainly in terms of organized religion,
uh,
the middleclass goes to church more than ordinary people,
then,
then workers,
uh,
for sure.
And in the case of,
of peasants,
it depends on where,
because as I said before,
in many parts of France,
the example that some,
well studied,
you still had this deep Christianization,
but certainly religion was a fundamental part of,
of the British middleclass as view of itself.
Uh,
and this,
the percentage of people who went to church could of course be exaggerated.
There was a study in,
in all of England,
uh,
I don't think it was in Wales and Scotland,
but in at least it was an England maybe in Wales to probably in wheels as well.
I think it was in the 1851 where they decided to look at every single church in,
in,
in England and Wales,
let's say,
and to see how many people went to church.
And they found to their horror that it was less than that than they thought.
And they also discovered that if,
uh,
if everybody had wanted to go to church,
had gone to various churches,
Methodists from ordinary people,
Anglican Catholic,
uh,
for the Irish and for a certain minority of,
of,
uh,
of British citizens or Jews in the east and going to synagogue and the east end
of London that there wouldn't have been,
they couldn't have accommodated all these people.
So there's a massive kind of church building campaign that go,
that has its counterpart in,
in almost every country as well.
Certainly in France.
After the Paris commune of 1871,
they start building churches in working class districts perched on the edge of,
uh,
of cities.
More about that in another lecture.
But,
but certainly,
I mean,
one go on and on about this,
but certainly religion for the middle classes has a,
has a much a greater role in their life.
Then in,
uh,
um,
then in working class working class cities and in the case of the peasants with
worn any peasants left in England.
And I'll talk about that and it'll be fun to talk about,
uh,
one of these lectures.
Uh,
but,
uh,
anyway,
there we go.
Now how many people were,
would have considered themselves middleclass and again,
self identity,
how people thought of themselves,
uh,
is one of those,
um,
aspects that we want to,
uh,
we'll want to discuss.
Um,
how do we know?
I mean,
how would you know,
uh,
who is middleclass when they first start doing censuses and census is a really
are 19th century phenomenon.
They begin with what and subsequent centuries.
As I said before,
there were only the first sentence is in Copenhagen,
I think.
And,
and,
uh,
in the 18th century,
the first real censuses don't do not come until the 19th century,
almost everywhere.
I mean,
it didn't ask people,
are you,
uh,
they asked you your name and where you lived.
Uh,
they,
in some cases they ask you your profession,
but they did not say,
are you middleclass are you not middle class?
Uh,
so there was a whole lot of work done in the 1970s and what they used to call
the new urban history,
which is sort of counting people up and deciding who might well have considered
themselves a middle class.
Um,
there are a lot of dissertations written on that kind of thing.
There was one in the case of Paris,
I never really have to talk to someone about Paris because the work is so rich
there.
A woman called Adeline,
Doma wrote a dissertation that was felt to published called the Bush White House
[inaudible],
the bourgeois of Paris and the first half of the 19th century.
And so,
um,
what she did is she looked at,
at wills,
the middle class people had enough money to leave wills,
uh,
and,
and therefore their inventories after death.
That's what,
what you call them,
inventories after death.
And that's one of the reasons we know about the explosion of print culture
because they inventory the books that people read.
I mentioned this in the context of,
of enlightenment to,
because you do have that too,
but,
uh,
taking the kinds of way that she looked,
ways that she looked at social class.
Um,
she determined that somewhere between 17 and 19% of the prison population in the
first half of the 19th century would have been considered considered bourgeois
and would have considered themselves bourgeois.
That is in the middle class,
says now,
certainly in,
in Britain,
the percentage is higher.
It probably approaches 25%.
I can't remember the exact figures.
Um,
and,
and that percent will continue to increase in the 19th century.
And you can already very well anticipate from you already know where other parts
of Europe that have have large,
important middle classes,
the old Hanseatic port cities of German and the German freeze to cities that
would become part of unified Germany in 1871.
Uh,
and in northern German cities in general,
light like,
uh,
Bremen and,
and,
and uh,
and Lubeck and Homburg above all they have,
I mean,
homburgs a huge port city,
so it's got the very normous wars was the,
uh,
you know,
you,
if you went to Madrid,
you'd find a sizable middle class,
but it would be nothing that you would have a,
if you compared to Madrid to,
um,
to Barcelona because Barcelona is a really natural economy based upon,
uh,
important economic relations between its hinterland and Barcelona and between
Barcelona and the world because it's a major port.
So you've got this big teaming middleclass there as well.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
in the case of France,
I mean,
obviously places that have lots of industry have,
have,
you know,
I had small businesses have middle class people,
uh,
in,
in large numbers.
So not as large numbers as workers.
I mean,
Leon would be a good example.
Leo has the most tightly closed middleclass as you can imagine.
It still is.
I mean,
all,
it was very,
very [inaudible].
Uh,
what can wouldn't say.
and again,
northern Italy,
you find a huge vibrant middle class,
but not in southern Italy.
I mean,
uh,
Naples is one of the biggest cities,
in,
in Europe,
uh,
right through the early modern period.
And you've got a large middle class,
but most of Italy is a extremely rural.
And what you have,
what you had in Rome with was,
uh,
you had clergy enrollment,
but you hate you.
It's a city.
So we've got important middle class.
The further east you get the smallest,
the middleclass a smaller,
the middle class gets a Russia that the estimates are about 2% of the population
are,
uh,
we're,
we're middleclass 2%,
which isn't very much at all.
And of course,
they are clustered in Moscow and in Saint Petersburg,
uh,
and in Kiev.
Now,
Ukraine,
uh,
always Ukraine,
but then part of a part of Russia,
uh,
in the large cities in Poland,
Warsaw,
I had a large,
I was just at the history museum and fascinating one a of Warsaw Museum,
um,
uh,
a couple months ago and in Warsaw as Krakoff ha ha,
Krakow had Krakoff ha had a big middle class.
Uh,
Gdansk obviously cause it was a port city,
but much of Poland was rural and wouldn't have that kind of,
uh,
Middleclass Belgrade would,
would've been the only city in the Balkans,
outside of his Tan bull with a and envelope assembles and in the Balkans.
But what with uh,
uh,
with,
an important middle class.
I mean,
this is all perfectly obvious anyway.
Who are these folks and what do they want?
Um,
so I mean,
they're not all,
how am I going to do this?
I'm going to,
can I need those fights?
I'm gonna do it like this.
You have to imagine the middleclass like this,
that it's a pyramid.
It's a pyramid with a small top and a big bottom.
Uh,
and that,
and I'll give you some rather interesting,
um,
show you a lithograph that really represents this.
Two of these in very,
in very interesting ways.
I think a,
a compelling ways at the beginning,
at the very top.
And this,
you know,
if you take a think of a Zurich or think of,
I mean,
any city you want,
Zurich has a big middle class.
So the Geneva for obvious reasons,
uh,
but the very top there are the,
the,
the great bourgeoisie,
the big boars was,
and these are people who have,
who are big finance,
Sears,
uh,
in the 19th century,
bankers will become much more important for perfectly obvious reasons.
Uh,
these are big wholesale merchants,
uh,
who are making bundle shipping things from here to there.
You won't get fine lawyers and people like that.
Um,
and what also makes them the high bourgeoisie or the Big Boys?
Was he a small percentage?
It doesn't really matter.
Uh,
where this line goes is that they have access to political power,
uh,
that to even if they are,
even if they're in PR,
in Prussia,
a place that's dominated by the nobles who are called the Younkers,
as most of you know,
uh,
they will still have access by virtue of their wealth to political power,
which is exactly the way they want it.
And there's a revolution in France in 1830,
yet another one that you can read about.
And arguably,
I mean,
more access.
And in a way it's sort of true.
What it does is it brings to Fran,
uh,
power and France,
the big boars was the,
and they have the ear of the King Louie Felipe who calls himself to a citizen
King.
He would rule from 1830 to 1848.
And in the,
the,
the portraits of him,
the paintings that he had done to represent who he was very different than those
of the Bourbon kings.
The Bourbon kings are all looking like,
you know,
even the kind of pathetic successors of Louis the 14th,
uh,
they're looking like big people in Chateaus,
who are kings of all that they see,
which of course was more or less the case.
Louis Felipe's view of himself with it.
He was the citizen citizen King.
That's what he calls himself.
He's still the king.
He was knowable.
He was not any bourgeois,
but in the official paintings of him,
you'll Hugh see people dressed like me who are coming into the throne room.
They're dressed like me in dark suits and they have power and he wants them in
the painting with him.
That's terribly revealing is terribly interesting.
So these are people,
these are big bankers,
high finance,
here's at the top.
Um,
and then you've got,
you know,
you've got other layers of,
uh,
of which was he and you,
and you could kind of fill in the gap here.
We have smaller bankers not in size,
but you know,
in money,
uh,
industrialists,
merchants,
these kinds of people and don't obey the great character,
tourists,
least favorite people,
lawyers,
uh,
be,
you know,
rise up rapidly in,
in,
in popular esteem.
Uh,
in usefulness in the middle class.
Likes to see themselves as useful.
Uh,
and so you,
you find lawyers reaching,
uh,
in there and,
and slowly doctors.
Cause remember,
doctors had very low social status.
They were sort of a cut above a bad pun.
I making what you read,
uh,
you know,
ordinary,
uh,
field surgeons,
during the Napoleonic battle,
some of whom were butchers or people that knew how to wield a knife.
Uh,
and you know,
doctors increase the self identity and become more important in the 19th
century.
You also find notaries no matter what country you're in.
Notaries.
Now notaries,
hold all,
have a much bigger role in Europe than they do here.
Notaries,
they know where all the goodies are.
When you buy property,
by the way in France,
uh,
you buy property,
you pay,
if you have a mortgage,
you pay 12% of right off the top,
goes to the notary just for holding in his office.
Your deed.
If you don't have a mortgage,
a you pay 7% right off the top.
So notaries know all of the secrets of people with money.
So notaries are important in all of these countries,
um,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I mean,
you can kind of fill in the occupation,
but they share things together.
Then at the bottom you have the petty bourgeoisie and everybody's poking fun at
the petty bourgeoisie,
but they too had a self identity.
My phone one day in the stacks of the library,
the University of Michigan,
a pamphlet that was actually,
uh,
it was,
a report on the w surely must have been the last,
but any case was the first world congress of the petty bourgeoisie and where
they met appropriately enough in Brussels.
Can you imagine going to a con,
you know,
professional history conferences,
they all have their little name tags and all they do,
they start up your body and look at your name tags and see if it's worth looking
at your face.
I mean,
it's really pathetic.
Uh,
and,
and can you imagine going to a conference like the world,
the congress of the petty bourgeoisie and you know,
a high,
you know,
world congress of the petty,
but which was the,
hi,
my name,
my name is out of bear.
Uh,
but they had a self identity now who were in the petty bourgeoisie.
Well,
lots of these classically new 19th century professions,
school teachers,
school teachers were,
uh,
were,
a way of social mobility for peasant families,
whether they were in Italy,
whether they were in Germany,
whether they're an Australia,
whether or hungry,
whether they're in Switzerland,
no matter where they were.
And I'll out of the working class or out of the peasantry,
um,
female school teachers become increasingly more important.
They always were the,
in Catholic schools because there were nuns,
you know,
with the big hats and all that.
Um,
and,
and very doing very good job,
even though often they were undereducated and it was kind of hard for them to do
that.
But school teachers you'd find here and also a cafe owners or tavern owners,
vine Staub owners in a,
I'm just giving you,
you know,
a couple of examples,
but these are,
these are the petty bourgeoisie and also very importantly,
what do you do with artisans and craftsmen?
Master artisans,
they own the tools that they're journeymen work with.
They rent or own their shops when things are doing,
going pretty well.
They do pretty well themselves.
But when things aren't going well,
they don't do well.
And that's why they're on the barricades.
All these times,
as you know,
in the French Revolution,
the French revolutions and in the revolutions of 1848 issue,
she'll discover in Vienna and Berlin and other places,
they're always there.
So these folks are here too.
Um,
and uh,
so this,
this is your basic,
you know,
petty bourgeoisie and people are always a dumping all over them.
But I will give,
uh,
needlessly,
but I will give you some example now in,
in order to,
if you ever read that the Great French Sha,
oh,
he was paid by the word.
As you can see when he has a description of a single sofas that go on for about
two pages.
But BALZAC Balzac is really the,
you know,
the,
the novelist of the bourgeoisie
when he describes Paris and,
and the 17 to 19% of the population who are increasingly living in the western
part of Paris.
More about that.
Another time he describes it as a jungle that you count your money in the
morning and then you count your money when you come home.
By the way,
your wife,
uh,
who would,
in the census we listed as not working.
If you were a shopkeeper,
your wife was the one who kept care of the accounts.
Your wife was the one who is by behind the counter when you were working,
when you're an artisan.
So he just describes us as a jungle.
So in order to get to,
to really give it an image of what that was like.
He's got it.
I got to find this thing someplace.
But,
uh,
he's got this one magnificent print called the street of the four winds and
that's a street in Paris though.
Who would they cut to?
A wall that's near,
um,
near old,
young.
It doesn't matter.
But here's a guy dressed like me.
See there's a theme in this.
He's dressed like me and he's wearing his bourgeois had,
I don't have one of those.
My only hat says it has an m for Michigan on it.
Uh,
and the hat,
his one suit isn't going to blow off his body,
but the wind is taking his hat,
which is a symbol of who he is and the wind is carrying it away from his hand
and in,
in,
in several hundred brush stokes strokes,
Joe,
me,
mea captures the look of panic on his face because he's going to go home without
his hat.
And his wife's going to say,
where's your hat?
And said,
well,
the wind blew it away and he's got to buy one.
And they've got to put the money together so he is not going to fall off the
ladder in this jungle.
So then you have to imagine this is a,
as a ladder,
like this,
social mobility is the goal and you want to have enough,
uh,
enough money to leave to your 2.2 children.
Um,
so then to really make this go,
you'd have to vines up here like the jungle and then,
and then you'd have to grease this pole through bad economic times.
Let's say in Europe,
Don't write this down.
Please don't if you do your compulsive,
I'm compulsive.
But 18,
41 really bad when 1846,
47,
1855.
Those are the really bad years.
And at that point,
if you don't get credit,
that's what's going on.
Now here she can't get credit because people withdraw the credit.
Same thing.
Then here you go.
Look out below you slide down this Paul,
and what happens down below here?
Holy cow,
that's the big C.
There's just a wretched movie called the Poseidon Adventure once,
but it had an image where the,
you know,
the water's kind of coming up below and it's going to finally get to the top and
there's no more room to breathe.
And this is how the people on the bottom part of this ladder viewed the demands
of the working class because they want to vote too.
And what if they voted,
vote in somebody who wants to raise your taxes or something like that.
Boy,
Oh boy,
that's scary.
But what's down here?
This is ordinary people.
This is the other 70.
What would it be in the case of Paris,
uh,
83% of the population and you're going to fall into that ranks of the
proletariat if you're on those bottom,
bottom,
uh,
if you're,
if,
if you're on the,
on the bottom kind of rungs here,
uh,
and so this has got to be,
this is your jungle and you're trying to make it up there to the big time.
And uh,
the chances are that in these bad years,
ah,
you're going to a fall down.
But yet lots of people get up in the ranks of,
of,
of the,
uh,
of the middle classes increases everywhere in the 19th century in Russia to
everywhere.
Uh,
that simply the case.
Now,
if I could just bring down
this,
so what I'm doing,
yeah,
that's what I'm doing.
Bring down that and show you how this works.
Had talked about some accoutrements of middleclass culture that you will
recognize.
Many of you now,
this is the guy at the top.
This is domain.
A domain is the greatest card characters just in the 19th century,
and arguably ever,
uh,
to make an extreme assertion,
but it really is a pretty true.
Um,
and so this is what he captures,
uh,
the,
the prevailing mood in much of Europe,
uh,
in that money,
more than blood,
if you're going to exclude places like Hungary,
Poland,
uh,
Spain,
um,
and,
uh,
Prussia,
um,
money talks more than,
uh,
than blood.
And so what does the man doing?
He's counting his money.
I remember I said that,
you know,
you counted your money in the morning and then you came home at night and,
and uh,
and,
and count your money again and see how you've done,
uh,
Miss Dameon these people.
No,
this is great.
Cause remember I said the,
the,
you know,
the variations within the bourgeoisie.
You can see this,
some of these images,
I mean this is really not very interesting art,
but that's not the point.
Look what this shows.
Now,
here's your,
the guy at the left here is a clerk that's a very 19th century,
a profession as it is for every,
uh,
every subject.
I,
he's,
by the way,
this is before the 1816,
because that's when the real fountain pens or invented,
he's got your basic quill pen there.
Now look at the coat.
They both have coached like mine,
but there's huge difference in them.
This guy,
if you have extraordinary eyes,
you will be able to see and can read upside down that he is reading a newspaper
on the price of colonial goods imports.
And he is a wholesale Merson.
So he's one of these people that's at the very top of my a triangle there.
Um,
and look at,
this guy's got his coat too.
This is early in the century.
You can tell,
uh,
now this is either the son in law or there would be son in law and he's put his,
you know,
the abortion was,
he didn't kiss and a hug a lot.
Uh,
but he's got his hand drape rather daintily on the old guys,
the arm here.
He's not about to embrace him and give him a kiss,
a big kiss on each cheek.
Uh,
and one day all of this stuff will be his,
uh,
if he plays his cards right.
Uh,
and they still had arranged marriages.
I mean,
love could count for something,
but,
but marriages were,
we're still essentially less so for the middle classes,
but then for ordinary people,
but economic relationships,
that's what they were.
There were economic relationships,
a wrangling over the,
uh,
the dowry and that kind of thing.
Now what about,
look at our,
our,
our guy on the left,
he's working very hard there.
And this pole that is put up there has a real sense of,
of dividing these.
So it's like the barriers on my quite arbitrary and not terribly well designed
triangle there.
Uh,
do these people have something in common?
Yes,
they will in 1830 and they will in 1848,
but the rest of the time they don't.
He's dreaming about being this guy and it,
but if you'll work very hard and,
and he's educated,
uh,
he will have had,
um,
probably not secondary education.
Most people didn't,
didn't go to a high school,
Secondary Lycee,
uh,
in France or,
or Gimnasio in Germany,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
but you know,
it,
it represents this world.
And this guy,
by the way,
we also know that this guy,
uh,
his,
um,
this,
this takes place right in the center of Paris,
right behind the big department stores.
Subsequently,
uh,
the,
oh,
tell Devita but right.
I the ashtray,
that was our low to the V,
which is a big department store,
but right near the town hall.
So anyway,
there we go.
Now,
this is another,
uh,
this has got to get my watch,
so I can keep track of things here.
Uh,
this is another,
a Vr,
this is very common.
You see this in the book you're reading and saying,
but,
um,
these things have their geographic,
uh,
or,
or I mean they can be represented a spatially very easily.
And one of the themes over the long run is that the emergence of city increased
development of,
of prosperous,
western Paris,
prosperous,
western London,
a center,
Vienna and other places,
and increasingly impoverished east,
east and the periphery.
And that's another theme,
but steel through much of the period.
And it need to,
to a lesser extent still today,
uh,
where you live in a building,
depending on reflecting how much money you had.
Now the ground floor in French called them of,
she'll say,
you know,
this is the concierge there.
And the concierge will be somebody very modest means,
uh,
you know,
we would probably place them in the,
in the,
in the petty bourgeoisie there.
And then the big apartment,
uh,
on the main,
on the first floor,
you know,
high ceilings,
big party.
I'll be,
lots of people dress like me.
They're a piano.
More about pianos in a minute.
Uh,
so this is my triangle sort of upside down,
isn't it?
And the more you go up there,
the,
you're still within the middle class.
The guy above,
he's got these little Napoleonic beds there.
This guy got hope.
He started closing his ears against his own baby there.
But no,
obviously,
because that's the,
uh,
this is a different house,
but he's a musician.
This is all rather banal,
but nonetheless telling you got an artist up here with not much money,
but he still has a little bit of furniture,
not much.
Uh,
his nosy neighbor looking at his painting.
And then on the top you've got the poorest of the mall besides the cat who's on
the roof up there.
You've got a seamstress and anyone looking at this very popular lithograph would
immediately see that she has some dignity left.
Why?
Because she has not yet pawned her mattress.
And there's a lot,
his great novel,
lost some wows.
Your vest dies like a dog and a bed of Straw because there was no more mattress
and she was be at the very top.
And now of course,
these,
these rooms,
which then became in the 20th century student rooms,
and then we're transformed into enormously expensive loss.
Uh,
but this steel,
this is a way of visually visualizing the spatial concomitants of what I'm
talking about.
And people were aware of what the symbols meant.
And He,
I mean,
this was,
this is your classic,
uh,
Homburg finance here is apartment.
Uh,
and we don't need to go on and on about the,
the,
uh,
the kind of material culture of wealth.
But,
but there it is.
So let's go on and on about it.
And another one that's easier to pick up for your eyes there.
Um,
this,
here again,
we know we're on one of the lower floors.
Why?
Because you see the trees outside the window.
Uh,
you've got a domesticated animal,
you know,
ordinary people,
it didn't have as many domesticated dogs had a real purpose.
They,
they bring the sheep down the mountain.
My wife just came down the mountain two weeks ago,
bringing the sheep down,
uh,
from friends of ours in the village.
And you know,
all of these dogs are useful things and keep the sheep in line and all of that.
Um,
you've got,
uh,
I mean this is all obvious stuff,
but you've got slippers,
ordinary people to not wear slippers.
You've got a domestic servant,
a domestic servants cost almost nothing.
Uh,
it was considered to be a way of moving up the ladder to say that you had for
domestic servers instead of three,
instead of three,
uh,
you've got a brass or copper here or the heater.
That's a good sign.
You've got very fancy chairs.
Look,
these,
these are very good chairs,
sort of Louie for leap chairs.
Uh,
you've got print culture,
a big old porcelain plate on the above there,
and you've got that wordswag coach from at the piano.
The Piano replaces the Harpsichord,
the piano.
Uh,
you know,
it,
it just,
uh,
Leon Planning Guy who's in j college who's a retired professor of music,
has got great stuff on,
on this,
the role of role of the piano and the emergence of,
along with Bill Weber teaches it,
did teach it at,
uh,
where do you teach it at?
At Long Beach.
Um,
the,
the emergence of the,
of,
uh,
of the public concert as opposed to the Chateau concert or the church concert,
the public concert.
And along with that comes the piano.
Now,
pianos were expensive,
but the middle class has piano.
It's working.
People don't have pianos.
Middleclass people have pianos.
So you also see something else that's important here.
There's more than one room.
And you'll see in a minute,
there's even more than two rooms.
There are lots of rooms.
And what the middleclass wants all those people in that triangle,
they want privacy.
They want privacy.
They want their own rooms.
Uh,
so she's playing the,
uh,
other piano.
Well,
I mean,
it's all obvious stuff and there's the kitchen.
Now,
this is not the wife.
These are the domestic.
This is the domestic with her children,
uh,
who are part of the team has been hired to help run this,
run this household.
There are,
you get,
you see the trees were in the same apartment there and you have real,
real copper pots,
uh,
back before the Bush dollar,
you know,
people would buy,
bring back,
uh,
you know,
from,
from Paris and from Europe,
these enormously heavy copper pots.
I've carried so many of them back.
It's incredible.
Uh,
and that was a,
you know,
ordinary people did not cook with things like that.
Uh,
so,
uh,
there,
there we go.
I mean,
these are the kinds of symbols of,
of all of this.
Now,
um,
the,
the middleclass wants privacy and they also develop something else.
And this is how almost trite to say it because so many people have said it,
but,
uh,
and it can be exaggerated,
but the middleclass arguably helps create the notion of childhood,
uh,
that in many early morning painting,
early modern paintings,
children are,
are our PR trade as her little squished up adults and that sort of thing.
And,
and children come into their own in,
in the 19th century,
ordinary people,
ordinary peasants,
you know,
children,
everybody's,
uh,
they slept with the animals often along with the adults.
Uh,
uh,
most ordinary people and some of the worst tenements in,
in Europe where it,
we're in,
in Edinburgh,
uh,
and in Glasgow and in Lille,
in France,
but also in Berlin and lots of places.
There were no secrets.
Everybody slept in the same room.
I,
there were no secrets at all.
And well,
what the middleclass wants besides social mobility and access to a political,
uh,
power is they want space.
And so the notion of childhood,
you know,
childhood didn't exist for,
for ordinary people.
You started working,
helping out sole,
you know,
when you were five or six years old,
you started tending the,
the animals and the little courtyard is the,
is they would call it taking care of chickens and rabbits and things like that.
You know,
I'm working people,
their children went to work right away as soon as they can make anything.
And if they were,
if they're reporting and have jobs,
something were sent out to beg,
childhood became a middle class phenomenon.
It's should we,
sure nobles had children,
but it was a different way of bringing up your children.
Uh,
nobles did not send their children to,
uh,
to,
to public schools or even a private schools.
They were educated to some extent at least by a private tutors.
And so,
um,
even the notion of,
of the children's hour,
uh,
the children's room,
I mean,
the idea of a children's room of having your own room or rooms shared with a
sibling was something that was just inconceivable.
Uh,
for the majority of Europeans,
the vast,
vast majority of Europeans,
the children's hour,
I can even remember,
you know,
the horror show of being summoned for the children's hour when you're supposed
to come out,
when they were guests and run through your extraordinarily modest bag of tricks,
you know,
for the guests.
And then your resets are packing and says,
I couldn't play a note on a piano.
Had been been expelled from piano after two weeks.
Bye Bye.
And sent back to the,
to the playing fields,
uh,
by a nun,
in Portland,
Oregon.
I didn't have many,
many tricks to show,
but,
but the children's hour,
uh,
all of this stuff comes out of the middle class.
How about birth control?
For example,
how about birth control?
How about not having 10 or 11 children?
We have friends,
one of whom unfortunately just died.
Very older friends,
you know,
who are born in the 1930s,
early thirties in,
um,
uh,
in the south of France.
And one had 13 brothers and sisters and the other 11.
And they grew up in misery,
absolute misery,
very,
very Catholic family in the center of France.
Now the middleclass,
particularly the French middleclass day start reducing their children,
number of children in France in particular case because the,
the,
they get rid of that.
You could get around it by,
but primogeniture so the,
uh,
the plot of land has to be divided up into two or three or four or five or 12 or
what if you own no land,
not so good.
Uh,
so they begin having an o 2.2 children or something like that.
so birth control,
you know,
in some,
some parts of Europe,
people think that birth control really started with peasants and then moves up
the moves up to the upper classes.
But basically,
uh,
particularly the case of France where it's been like most things studied,
studied to death,
uh,
birth control really begins with the middle classes and they are limiting their
children so that their children can be,
uh,
you know,
fee son of and inherit,
inherit the business.
And hopefully I'd be left with enough money to make it go a print culture.
I mean that was just an example of,
you know,
the whole salon,
a salon that as a salon,
the idea of going to see art shows,
it really starts in the 18th century.
But you know,
the middle class wants to be seen rather like the Dutch,
uh,
um,
detrimental class in,
in that we talked about in the 17th century,
who wants to be seen having paintings and they wait in line to go to,
this is all a dome.
Yay.
Ah,
and this is the,
uh,
the,
you know,
the mall.
So the,
the,
the piece that you have to,
uh,
you're,
you're obliged to swallow,
uh,
after dinner.
And here's the little girl being trotted out to play a few notes for the,
uh,
quite board,
people who are,
who are sitting there,
um,
and,
uh,
waiting.
And even the idea of,
you know,
it,
this is,
it's your birthday papa.
It's,
it's your birthday.
You know,
you didn't take time out to celebrate a birthday if you were ordinary person and
having to get to the fields at four in the morning,
in the summer,
uh,
or going to work,
during the day.
Uh,
the culture of,
of childhood,
uh,
is a really all of their,
and also,
uh,
there's a whole notion of,
of,
and,
and here again,
this would probably fit rather awkwardly into the birth control,
uh,
birth control description.
But there's this whole sense of,
of,
of being prepared,
uh,
that emergence for the middle class.
And one of those sort of accoutrements.
I went,
when I gave a equivalent of this lecture,
I had a,
an old battered umbrella and I was trying to explain how people on the top rung,
we're trying to beat down people at the bottom and smashing the,
you know,
smashing this a umbrella,
sort of like,
you know,
uh,
imaginary of somebody smashing the guitar on stage.
Uh,
but the point is that that umbrellas come with the middleclass and they are
black umbrellas.
They are not these big colored things you have now the idea of protecting that
one suit.
I'm from Oregon.
We didn't carry umbrellas,
get it rained all the time anyway,
and I just lose it.
Uh,
you would.
But the umbrella is our PR,
our middleclass accoutrement along with the piano and along with the children's
room and along with the children's hour and along with the idea of not having
too many children,
uh,
and along with the top hat and with the idea of,
of,
uh,
of wanting access to information through the newspapers,
wanting the right to vote,
not probably not wanting those people down below one boy in the latter to vote,
but demanding that you have the right to vote.
They all share these things in common.
And lastly,
gazing at his watch.
Lastly in the last one,
minute,
35 seconds,
that that remains,
uh,
to me,
um,
the bourgeoisie,
the middle classes and this particularly true of Germany and France,
uh,
when of England to and have other places,
they want the right to bear arms.
They want to be in the national guard and the National Guard might
hypothetically be there in case there is,
there is an invasion of,
uh,
of France or,
or,
or Germany by,
uh,
I dunno,
I mean some,
some distant place,
the fins or something.
Most unlikely,
but the main reason that they wanted to join the national guard,
and you had to own property to be in the national guard,
you had to be defined as a property owning citizen to have the right to vote in
all of these countries.
The right to vote was defined until you have universal male suffrage by how much
taxes you paid,
how much property you own.
So you can measure where you are on this ladder by much taxes you paid.
They don't want to pay a lot of taxes.
But property,
uh,
reflects one's belief in one's own social worth.
And that's the way they looked at it.
No longer was that the worth of,
of,
uh,
of blood now.
So they formed these national guards,
particularly after revolutions and after 1848 or after 1830 and for while they
go march around.
But these are mainly there to protect them against the workers should one day,
all of these people try to rise up to come up,
climb up this ladder will,
you'll be down there to stomp on their fingers or to shoot them down.
Uh,
and so it doesn't last very long.
And then they pretty soon they,
this guy is tired.
He's,
hey,
this isn't Domii.
I don't know who it is.
Doesn't matter.
It's not very good.
But he's had it.
Uh,
he's freezing.
His wife is kind of looking at him like,
I don't know why you doing this stuff marching around in the middle of the
night.
Uh,
no one's going to rise up anyway.
This'll last is old blunder bus there on the left will be put back in the closet
or taken out too to slay deer or some damn thing.
Uh,
but that'll be the end of it.
And they'll turn it over to more,
uh,
professional,
repressive forces such as armies,
Domiguez and light lines.
And this is the last one disappear in this painting,
which is called the [inaudible].
Tom Known.
Yeah.
Don't write it down in Paris.
Uh,
it's a street that no longer exist.
It disappeared when [inaudible] built the boulevards and the 1850s and sixties,
it was selected to disappear because it recalled an event in the early 1830s
when these bourgeois panicked and start going into a house full of very ordinary
people and simply shooting them all,
simply shooting them and the light lines disappear with dome.
He did another one of these after massacre in 1848 in a wall and it's been lost.
We don't have it.
Route Trans known.
Yeah.
Hd Domi in a,
at the bottom left,
and the middle classes for all of their insistence that they have access to
information,
at least in the case of France,
they cheered on a press law in 1835 that kept Domii from tut touching political
scenes such as this which were deemed too sensitive.
And the root Transylvania where this happened in the center of Paris simply
disappeared,
uh,
didn't quite disappear from the collective memory of people thinking about a
presion things.
So in conclusion,
the more the middle class is extremely varied,
they share much.
They have a common material culture.
Uh,
they,
uh,
share a belief in achieved status as measured by the amount of property that you
had.
Uh,
they want devote,
they want a collective,
a collective voice in,
in decisions.
And for all of the,
the,
the variety for a,
within the middle classes,
uh,
so,
so beautifully described are depicted by [inaudible] and other people.
Uh,
they still,
when push came to shove a shared an awful lot in the bourgeois century that of
the 19th century.
Have a good weekend.
See you on Monday.